euromax highlights and here's your host
kaine hemstedt hi there and welcome to
our highlights of the past week which
this time around happened to include the
following stories
murder they wrote why scandinavian crime
authors are so successful
classical move lang lang and the berlin
philharmonic record an album
and ice queen a guide in norway leads
tourists around europe's biggest glacier
well the premium imperiale is often
referred to as the nobel prize for the
arts it was created in 1989 by the
japanese royal family to award lifetime
achievement in the fields that the nobel
overlooks namely painting sculpture
music architecture and theater and film
well worth about 112 000 euros it's a
very big deal for the recipients and
this year's britain's anthony gormley
took the honors for sculpture
sculptures that represent individuals
installations that make people the point
of focus or alternatively allow them a
bit of self-reflection
this is anthony gormley's art
gormley has been awarded the premium
imperiale which is presented by the
japanese royal family in honor of his
life's work it's one of the world's most
important arts prizes
any form of recognition is is wonderful
any form of encouragement is wonderful
but this comes from a special a special
place on the face of this earth and and
indeed from rather a special person
since the
emperor
is
partially divine
63 year old gormley lives and works in
london
he studied art at goldsmith's college
here in the 1970s and soon began to
specialize in sculpture
sculpture was the biggest challenge it
was not about making pictures of things
it was about making things
it wasn't about making a representation
of the world but about provoking the
world by putting something in it that
wasn't there before
and that seemed to me to be
both a more exciting intellectual
project but also a more exciting
physical one
one of his most spectacular projects was
unveiled in 2010 horizon field
the artist had 100 cast iron figures
installed across the austrian alps
life-size casts of his own body the
choice of unusual location is typical
for gourmet for many people
the natural home for a work of art is in
a museum
well that's a strangely
limbo land
for for art in my view art ought to be
just part of life
and precisely that has happened in
london where gormley's installations are
part of the cityscape
whether as a useful object in front of
the british library
or as a point of reflection amid the
hustle and bustle of the financial
district it's art without museums or
explanatory labels you need to discover
it yourself
if it is out on the street you go you'll
reach people who aren't necessarily
seeking it out and provoke a reaction
from them
the pieces are so close to people
because they're about the size of an
average person
so somehow that makes them very
accessible
accessible in a very different way that
was the goal for horizon field hamburg
it was a free swinging level in one of
hamburg's daistor holland and it was on
exhibit last year
visitors set the mirrored surface in
motion by walking on it thus themselves
becoming part of the installation
the life that comes to occupy this
opportunity
is the work not the peace
itself you could say that without people
art is nothing art is about
sharing
the first people the sculptor shares his
plans with are the staff at his studio
in london
the building was designed by british
architect david chipperfield
every time i walk in through that door i
think
this is
just magic that we can have a place in
central london where
you can put 50 tonnes down anywhere
the work continues gormley may now have
won one of the world's most prestigious
art awards the premium imperiale but
that doesn't mean he's successful in his
own eyes
success what does success mean success
really for me is is
only
measurable
in the ability of a silent still object
to touch somebody
and in the end
i will never know
how
successful or unsuccessful
i have been
anthony gormley's sculptures depict
people
his art aims to illustrate how it feels
to be a human being
long cold winters brooding landscapes
and stoic often troubled investigators
those are the key ingredients for a good
scandinavian crime novel and books by
authors like henning mankel and jacques
nesser literally fly off the shelves
well you see adler olsen of denmark is
carrying on in that grisly tradition and
he drew an impressive crowd at the
frankfurt book fair
you see adler olsen is riding high
the 63-year-old danish author is one of
scandinavia's top mystery writers
everywhere he goes whether at home or
abroad he draws a crowd
like here at the frankfurt book fair
he's a rock star of the literary world
i like it i like to be you know on the
level with my readers
you know this is what i'm aiming for
to be in bed with the readers when i'm
writing in the night time
and to be close to them when they are
here
his latest novel was published in
denmark last year
the german translation has been out for
a month and is already a bestseller it's
the fifth book in his series featuring
copenhagen police detective karl merk
set in uganda and copenhagen it's a dark
exploration of the underbelly of
international aid and corruption in high
places told through the story of marco a
young roma boy who discovers a murder
and becomes a target himself day and
night i was marco
and being marco
and
running away you know
all the time being chastened by people
that want to kill him i felt it really
on my back so every time i was in the
open right okay i escaped they were
there again
and therefore it's a little long you
know about chasing and therefore it is
actually
i'm closer to this book
than i i meant to
meant to be
the first book in the series was
published in 2007.
since then adler olsen has gone on to
write four more installments featuring
merck and his detective squad the books
have appeared in 36 countries each
german edition has been a best seller
they've sold millions of copies in total
you can't enter the best selling list
very easily in countries where they
speak english only because they prefer
their own
but here in germany all of us are
competing on the same level
same best-selling list for everyone
throughout the world and if if you can
enter that
you actually can enter the whole world
the worldwide boom got its start with
swedish author henning mankell in the
1990s his thrillers took on weighty
topics like africa politics and
xenophobia at home
he was followed by many more like lisa
markland
another swedish star was stig larson who
died in 2004.
nowadays scandinavian crime fiction is
the hottest game in town
dubious gauless is a journalist book
critic and member of the jury for the
german crime fiction award he keeps a
close eye on the trends
in a sense these scandinavian novels are
like a mirror for european and german
readers
scandinavians feel certain things more
keenly than we do the countries the
societies actually have more security
than we do here
so they respond hysterically when this
security is threatened
their writing takes on this collective
fear this sense of anxiety which exists
here too
in dramatic form
scandinavia may present an unruffled
surface to the casual observer but
underneath it's teeming with bleak
plotlines and angst-ridden protagonists
nordic noir where little is what it
seems
germans feel an affinity with the
scandinavians and are fascinated by
their society their crime novels tend to
focus on social issues it's often said
that crime novels have replaced regular
fiction as a genre in terms of observing
society
this latest installment won't be the
last
adler olsen is planning another five
books in his department q series
and even in germany you see adler olsen
enjoys giving a reading in the original
danish
he's a born entertainer in real life and
on the page
well this past week dw was proud to
present another top-notch music
documentary and it explores a
collaboration that is so charged with
energy it almost gives off sparks the
world famous berlin philharmonic with
conductor sir simon rattle teamed up
with chinese superstar pianist lang lang
for a couple of landmark recordings and
our very own christian berger got the
story on film which premiered here in
berlin
spring 2013.
the famous berlin philharmonic concert
hall hosts a top caliber international
summit of classical music
chinese pianist langlang has teamed up
with the berlin philharmonic orchestra
and its conductor sir simon rattle for
their first joint recording
the stars aren't bothered by the cameras
i'm actually used to it you know because
i i do a lot of documentary films around
year round
and i actually like to deliver
some ideas
while i'm
making the recording so for me it's a
kind of a fun thing to do
the result was the hour-long documentary
the highest level
lang lang returned to berlin for the
premiere
the highest level is the third film
about classical music by dw's christian
berger
is a very professional musician an
artist that knows exactly what he wants
but he still gave us a lot of leeway
he had confidence in us and gave us a
glimpse of his personal life
and he spoke with us very openly about
music which was also very nice
the premiere was attended by about 500
classical music fans
dw as co-producer played a major role in
producing the documentary
films about music are a speciality of
the network
this was a great project with artists
like lang lang and simon rattle
and simon rattle it was a really big
catch and i'm delighted that a fantastic
production like this will be broadcast
on dw soon on the network and online
it makes me proud that we achieve
we like to see how the rest of the world
engages with germany and we engage with
them
this project gave us lang lang from
china
in collaboration with simon rydel from
britain with the philharmonic in berlin
an international orchestra
that's typical of dwc
and a perfect topic for us
the film depicts the process of
recording two pioneering works of the
20th century
piano concerto number three by russian
composer sergey prokofiev and piano
concerto number two by his hungarian
contemporary bela bartok
let's just do a take shall we see what
yeah so
it's a very musical
clips
and also
it was a real good documentary
there are a lot of comments from
different parts of the teammates
for this project i think will be very
helpful
to people who don't know so much about
how we're making
recordings
and this is
a real team work to make
the best we can
the cd is already out the film will be
released on dvd and blu-ray in early
november
you can tune in to dw on november 30th
to see the documentary in german english
spanish or arabic
well every year in october berlin hosts
a two-week-long festival of lights that
floods the city's monuments and
buildings in color and light after
sundown theresa mar is an austrian light
artist from vienna who is now a veteran
at this event and our reporter caught up
with her to see what she had in store
for the german capital this year
teresa mar at the dress rehearsal the
evening before the festival of lights
opens
it's only when the slides are projected
onto the building that the artist knows
if all the months of work have paid off
wow
looks great it's there for the first
time and it's totally new for me a big
surprise
ma has completed eight light collages
for the pallayam festoons grab
festungsgraben in central berlin she
wants her work called prisma to change
the perception of the building
the substance of my work begins with
white light
when it falls on raindrops you have a
rainbow it makes you want to look twice
and that's how it is with this building
this projection will certainly make
berliners look at it closely
theresa ma works intuitively she says
her images fit together like a puzzle
first she creates a collage from 200 to
300 paper snippets that she's cut out of
magazines
the finished image is scanned
she then edits and processes it on her
computer till she's satisfied
theresa mars says she is a painter who
uses different ways to present her art
her canvas involves public spaces and
buildings which he paints in bright
colors
you obviously have to have a talent and
drive in implementing things
without it you can't have a profession
like this
i can imagine how an image can appear in
a larger dimension
ma presented her first work in vienna in
2006.
her international breakthrough came at
the glow lights festival in the
netherlands in 2010
a year later she brightened up berlin
cathedral at the festival of lights
in 2012 her installation sinfonia lit up
the concert house at berlin's
jean-darmanmarkt
this year her images can be seen on two
buildings together with other artists
teresamar has once again illuminated
berlin cathedral
in berlin
berlin has huge buildings and sprawling
squares
this city has a feel for space it's
perfect for a light projection and
this is perfect for an elite project
zone the festival of lights is to
brighten the german capital for 12
nights famous artworks give a new look
to potsdamer platz
the brandenburg gate has huge
three-dimensional images known as video
mappings
and the facade of the hotel de rome
boasts some old masters
the lights festival has already become a
tourist magnet organizers expect around
2 million visitors
gorgeous colors
amazing it changes the building's
character and makes it more cheerful
looks very spectacular now
rainbow colors everywhere
i simply like it when you see so many
lights and colors in the night you don't
notice that it's cold and windy in that
it's autumn
helps this
these light images are like snapshots
for teresa martin's part of her concept
she wants viewers to reflect for a
moment and keep the image in their
memories
nyx has come to see the next thing is
i'll be illuminating the emitage in
amsterdam
that's a 100 meter long facade and i'll
be using a moving image
and then we'll see if i'm back in berlin
next year
and otherwise there are a few buildings
in the world that fascinate me and draw
me and that i would like to illuminate
someday
one of her dreams is to light up the
philharmonic in luxembourg and to bring
art to the streets there too
the festival of lights does add a splash
of color to berlin's autumn nights
well its ice is almost twice as thick as
the eiffel tower is high the monumental
yostada glacier in norway and with a
surface area of almost 500 square
kilometers it's the largest glacier on
continental europe as you can see here
it drapes itself over three large fjords
in southwestern norway about 300
kilometers northeast of bergen and it's
one of that area's major tourist
attractions and we met the only woman
who can take you across it
the norwegian glacier yostada's plane is
a colossus of snow and ice
it's the star attraction here in yostata
valley
heidi zimmerman who originally hails
from switzerland has been working here
since 1990 guiding people around
continental europe's largest glacier
my name is heidi
and i wish you all welcome on the
glacier it will come one more guide his
name is arno
the tour kicks off with a 30 minute boat
trip across the glacial lake
a chance for the group to catch their
breath ahead of the ascent to nigard's
plane a sidearm of yostata's plane
you see those people those tiny dots up
there we'll be going higher than them
you see that ridge which crosses the
valley
we'll be going about as far as that
each year heidi takes about 10 000
people on tours around the glacier
today's group is an international bunch
as well as norwegians there are
australian dutch and german tourists ice
climbing is a popular pastime but that's
nothing new the first norwegian
mountaineers ventured out onto the
yostatasplain in 1880 their equipment
was pretty basic a canvas rook sack a
stick and light cotton clothing but they
approached the endeavor in a very
similar manner rope together in a group
and of course i will check everything
safety is very important but i will not
check before i put you in rope because
then i have control
that i can check everyone
heidi knows exactly what to look out for
mountaineering is her passion
in switzerland she was the second woman
to become a certified mountain guide
she's a pioneering figure in norway too
the only female mountain guide in the
whole country
and even after twenty three years she
says she never gets bored on the
yoshita's plane
conditions change every day on the
glacier it moves up to a meter a day
it can be transformed in a week
it's always a challenge to find a new
path
i like having to constantly respond to
new people you can do more with some of
them with others
the day tour lasts five hours and ends
at a very special place
at the foot of the glacier where water
rushes into the valley at 10 000 liters
a second
it's a beautiful but treacherous spot
this
it's a wonderful blue color and so
people are tempted to go very close
but if that breaks away it'll dam up the
whole river
that will cause a huge flood wave
capable of washing people away so i see
it as the most dangerous place of any
glacier much more dangerous than
clevases
as soon as she's back in yostata valley
heidi heads off to the mountains again
this time she's accompanied by her dogs
the mountains are her refuge
of course climbing on your own is
different than when you are responsible
for other people
you don't have to make concessions
you can choose your own company
so i go on more difficult tours than i
would with visitors i love being in the
mountains more than anywhere else
and in a way that's hardly surprising
for someone whose name is heidi and who
comes from the swiss alps
and that brings us to the end of this
edition of our euromax highlights i hope
you enjoyed it and until we meet again
all the best from us here in berlin
you